grazie a tutti un giorno mi trovavo in
un ufficio l'ufficio che non era molto
lontano da qui e ancora non avevo deciso
di preciso cosa avrei fatto
all'università e dissi che ero non
vedente e che volevo studiare
informatica e la risposta che mi fu data
mi lasciò di stucco perché fu tu un
cieco che vuole studiare informatica
tu sei pazzo queste furono le risposte
che mi furono date sono vincenzo rubano
ho 21 anni e sono iscritto al terzo anno
del corso di laurea in informatica
presso l'università di bologna
lei è mary soul ed è il mio cane guida
quella di cui voglio parlarvi oggi è una
strada un po particolare se vogliamo
forse anche un po rivoluzionaria
passatemi il termine ma voglio voglio
voglio raccontarvela per lasciarvi un
messaggio ma per capire questa strada
bisogna partire dalle origini perché
permettetemi di rubare una citazione ma
la qualità di un mobile si vede dal
pannello posteriore quello che nessuno
quasi mai si prende la briga di guardare
e quindi questa strada parte dalle
origini parte da un bambino un bambino
piccolo che cresce dentro casa sapendo
che si è vero non vede ma che la
mancanza della vista comporta dei
problemi tanti più o meno difficili ma
che spesso in qualche modo possono
essere superati e quel bambino cresce
cresce con gli attrezzi della cassetta
con cui smonta i suoi giocattoli perchè
ha scoperto che ci sono un triciclo ed
una motoretta che se sbottati hanno un
sacco di spazio dove poter conservare i
giocattoli e altri attrezzi per smontare
altri giocattoli questo bambino che
cresce con l'idea che bisogna farsi
bisogna far rispettare i suoi diritti
fin da bambino fin da quando bisogna
farsi accettare dagli altri bambini e
far rispettare quelli che sono i proprio
diritti perché appunto non vedere non
significa non poter giocare e non
potersi integrare e questo lo devo a due
figure che sono lì in mezzo a voi e che
mi hanno fatto crescere con questa
immagine e permettetemi una piccola
digressione per esprimere da qui da
questa posizione un piccolo ringrazio
ma questa strada è piena di tante tappe
di tante cose interessanti su cui
purtroppo dovrò sorvolare e così si
arriva un bel giorno ad un'idea ad una
piccola realizzazione in occasione della
giornata m'illumino di meno ma ci vedo
di più
giornata in cui io decisi di lanciare un
sondaggio chiamato appunto m'illumino di
meno ma ci vedo di più perché partita
l'idea che chi non vede delle luci che
si accendono e si spengono
non se ne può render conto e allora ho
detto ok
accendo un sondaggio per dimostrare che
chi non vede il computer lo usa anche
per parecchio tempo e per farci le cose
più disparate e per dare un messaggio a
vari progettisti e programmatori che non
rendendo accessibili i propri prodotti a
chi non vede stavano compiendo una vera
e propria discriminazione
nient'altro perché chi non vede il
computer lo usa grazie ad una tecnologia
chiamata screen reader ossia un
programma che in grado di leggere
tramite una voce artificiale e tutto ciò
che compare sullo schermo
a patto ovviamente che questo sia
accessibile e grazie agli
incoraggiamenti ricevuti dopo questo
sondaggio
ho deciso di continuare questa battaglia
lanciando il sito ti tengo d'occhio un
sito che mira appunto a denunciare
pubblicamente tutti i programmi i siti
web che non sono accessibili per le
persone non vedenti e ho deciso di
proseguire ulteriormente lanciando la
campagna video for blind che permette a
chiunque pubblichi un video su una
piattaforma di video sharing di renderlo
accessibile anche a chi non vede anche
se questo video si basa essenzialmente
sulle immagini per trasmettere il
proprio contenuto e si può fare
attraverso dei piccoli accorgimenti che
non richiedono grandi conoscenze
tecniche e che sono alla portata di
chiunque semplicemente aggiungere una
descrizione delle immagini che faccia
comprendere il video anche se sia occhi
chiusi è la cosa più banale da fare e
questa strada prosegue prosegue con la
mia partecipazione alla drupal con
portland una conferenza a cui sono stato
invitato per il lavoro
sull'accessibilità che avevo fatto su
drupal un sistema che consente di
gestire contenuti e di creare
web che può essere modificato da
chiunque a cui sono stato invitato a
partecipare proprio per il lavoro che ho
fatto sull'accessibilità ma come disse
come dice helen keller camminare con un
amico al buio è meglio che camminare da
soli nella luce e così ad un certo punto
la mia strada si incontra con quella di
altri quattro non vedenti che grazie al
web decidono di fondare un portale
chiamato nv apple che mira a fornire
informazioni e notizie su tutto ciò che
ha a che fare con l'accessibilità dei
prodotti apple e su come questi possano
essere utilizzati dai non vedenti perché
apple è stata la prima compagnia grande
la prima grande compagnia ad integrare
on board
i suoi sui suoi prodotti sistemi che
consentono ai non vedenti di utilizzarli
appena usciti dal negozio e questo
progetto è andato avanti lanciando anche
un'altra una web radio che se vogliamo è
un'altra piccola rivoluzione perché è
una web radio che non ha uno studio di
registrazione e che trasmette 24 ore su
24 7 giorni su 7 e su cui per andare in
diretta è sufficiente avere uno
smartphone è una connessione internet
nient'altro e si va in diretta mondiale
e questa strada sarebbe piena di tante
altre tappe di tante altre cose che
purtroppo vorrei raccontarvi che vorrei
raccontarvi ma purtroppo credo che il
tempo a mia disposizione stia per
scadere e allora volevo concludere
questo racconto lasciandovi quello che è
il messaggio che poi vorrei che passasse
da questo mio talk ed è questo non è non
ho voluto fare questo talk a scopo auto
celebrativo ma piuttosto per lanciare
questo messaggio avere una di una
disabilità non significa avere davanti a
sé una strada interrotta non è un alt ci
possono essere delle deviazioni questa
strada può essere più o meno tortuosa
più o meno complicata più o meno in
salita ma è sempre una strada con una
partenza e un arrivo potrà essere più o
meno rivoluzionaria ma non sarà mai
interrotta grazie a tutti